[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pride of cincinnati ohio
played high school basketball there mick
cronin the
head coach of ucla bruins joining us on
the program not enough people
talk about your high school basketball
career there coach
uh you know i know you're playing for
lasalle
all city they're playing for your dad uh
do you want to talk about
uh who who plays the game the way you
played when you were in high school
let's just say my team plays a lot
better defense than i did
okay how tall your career wasn't it
mason
yeah dominated yeah domination yeah but
you read the stories but we don't need
to talk about my career this is about
your career
but how tall were you in high school so
i've been growing same height same
weight you know five
five seven 155 and uh
your dad is a high school legend as far
as coaching right he's got over 400 wins
yeah very lucky obviously to uh have
great parents grow up to son of a coach
you know coach huggins and i used to
always say we're products of our
environment
you know when you grow up in a gym you
just you you obviously uh
there's the osmosis process you're
learning
how to coach you're learning how to deal
with players you're learning because you
go home you learn how to coach things
you're a player
you hear what the other players say uh
so if you're really
training on the job you just you just
don't know it until until the day you go
to coach
and you realize like you know you
probably were trying to do what you're
doing your whole life
how cool is this that you get to share
this with your father
oh it's awesome you know it's i have a
lot of friends in coaching obviously and
you know some some guys
their dad's not around um you know so
for me
uh just for him to get to enjoy this to
get you know to give back
you know so many of us you know midwest
people
cincinnati people you know it's uh the
west side
hard-working people you know my dad had
three jobs
my mom worked full-time uh you know so
they put three kids through private
school i don't know how the hell they
did it
uh but they did it so you know when you
give anything back to your parents
it's a great thing in life because
obviously you know i wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for my parents
if i told you a month ago that we would
be talking today and it would have to do
with uh the final four what would you
have said
i just said we got really hot from the
three-point line but
you know i wouldn't have said no chance
but i just said you know we we
had to really get hot from a three-point
line so we're a smaller team dan
and uh we got but we do have guys can
shoot the basketball
uh and then the other thing i would say
was boy we we really must have gotten
better defensively
like way better and that's really what's
happened that's really the story
of what's happened for us since half
time in the michigan state game
we've really just transformed
defensively as a team but also
you know you look at this and it's hard
to say ucla is a cinderella story
but right i agree with you but but it's
still a cinderella this team is a
cinderella story though coach
oh yeah no i i understand um
i i you know if we win those last four
the regular season
we're not a cinderella and we could have
won all those games
uh we had some really bad breaks down
the stretch against
really good teams so i do you know that
puts you
down on the seed line and it makes you a
cinderella story
and then look you'd obviously as you
know dan in la
uh you know it's big names you know the
lakers
they don't go to the they don't win
title without lebron or
kobe uh you know magic kareem same thing
you know the bruins have had so many
great great players
uh and we got very good players on this
team we got to see them some guys that
are developing their chances to be
professional players
but you know kareem's not walking
through the door bill
walking through the door so you know
it's new for ucla to
to grind their way to a final four
what's it like though when you go into
paulie pavillion you look up and you see
all those banners
man it's awesome dan it's awesome
everybody's not intimidating
i don't really look at it like i just
you know maybe i'm too
too uh my irish toughness
um doesn't allow me like i don't think
that way i just think
i look at opportunity i think you can't
i should
if you're going to look at it in in awe
of oh my goodness
you know look what i have to live up to
um
you know that you shouldn't take the job
uh
but i did study everything that coach
wooden said at the end dan i mean when i
got the job i stayed up late and he
there's a quote from coach wooden he
said the only person that had
had to deal with my expectations should
have been my
the the first guy that followed him okay
um which was murray bartow but you know
after that
you you didn't follow john wooden and
this is him talking you know that so
he said if they're thinking that way
that that's the wrong way to think
so uh but anyway you know i just maybe
it's my stubbornness
but i just look at it as what an
opportunity to coach where
coach wooden coaches i've met all his
family they're texting me today
already that's great yeah just so many
cool people i mean i'm
dad i'm friends with kareem abdul-jabbar
how cool
he's uh mick cronin the uh ucla head
coach by the way
this just in roy williams has announced
his retirement
are you being serious yeah it just
happened uh
yeah carolina just released this after
33 years
as a hall of fame head coach our beloved
tar heels roy williams
announcing his retirement well i would
say from the coaching community
uh congratulations coach williams is a
great guy
and the side note i mean he's taking
care of me got me uh
hooked up down in pinehurst to play some
elite courses
[Laughter]
so uh i owe him now he's gonna be
i told him that now he's retired coach
come on out
we'll play bel air we'll play riviera
we'll play la north whatever you want
uh do you bother showing gonzaga tape to
your
players oh absolutely absolutely you
know
absolutely one thing i can say dan that
you know look we're obviously we're a
decided underdog that's okay
but in my big east days uh when i was
rebuilding cincinnati
unfortunately i have a lot of experience
in being a double-digit underdog
you know back in 0607.08 uh
so you know i had to deal with that
quite a bit
and we're not looking to do this but
there was many nights
that uh we got beat six that we could
have got beat 36. so
uh i have dealt with that situation um
but uh we'll see but yeah you know it
we'll approach the game uh like any
other but also
knowing it's gonna be tougher than any
other we've played this year
uh how tough are you though to play for
oh no i think you know what's funny man
when you're passionate
what my players all know for my problem
right now my cincinnati players want to
come to the game they've all
um they've banded together sent me texts
this morning
they all want to come to the game so i
get ticket issues
uh when you're i think people think look
he's all over them but they don't
it's encouragement 90 of its
encouragement
you know is that you can guard him you
know you can do this
uh you know i'm just extroverted with it
uh i'm outward with it
um so you know in practice uh
you know i think you got to bring energy
i learned that early there's a great nba
legendary workout guy tim gargridge and
kids
they want they want to feel your energy
i learned that from him as a young guy
when he was
gave me a chance to help him work guys
out
you know as you know players want to
feel a guy that's trying to help them
get better
and and that's how you know so they know
that so i'm not just barking at guys
uh to barking guys you know kids
wouldn't they wouldn't respond to that
but i remember i don't know if i met you
at the university of cincinnati when
huggins was there but you were
like video coordinator i think you
started out there yeah for nine months
then that you know then he got smart and
promoted
oh he promoted you
but the way huggins held at practice was
something unlike anything i'd ever seen
before
yes yes i totally agree
um how would you describe how huggins
would
would hold those practices at cincinnati
let's just
let's just you know for a people on the
outside it's hard you know because so
many co
people say i can't believe you said that
or that you know but players get it i
mean
you know when you get especially got you
know the guy locker room talk
it is what it is um you know in the
outer world academia
would just don't understand it um you
know it's just
how how the kids talk how it is at times
and
you know again you know bob huggins uh
coaches with love
and i give him a shout i would not be
here if it was not for him
but when you coach with love uh the kids
know it
so that you know they again they know
you're not messing with them you're
trying to bring out the
best in them because they know he would
do anything for his players the same the
same as i would
but i remember this is when nick van
exel was there
yeah and i just remember huggins saying
to the team
as somebody who shouldn't have been
shooting he just gathered him and he
he a couple of cuss words and then he
goes like guys this your team do you
want him
shooting like like and i and i'm
watching
with the former cincinnati great the
late derek dickey and he said just so
you know you're going to watch a
practice
and you're going to see something and
hear something you've never heard before
and he's saying to the players you guys
are accountable for what goes on on the
floor
do you want him shooting and the answer
is no you
so right in front of this poor guy i
don't want to mention his name but he
goes
and i know how it was
[Laughter]
trust me it was just so honest but you
know to be
brutally honest like you saw what
happened with coach izzo and the whole
you know like you he loves his players
but can you coach like that you know you
know
yeah i mean it's there and the visual of
what we saw and we're all like wow coach
you know get it together yeah the visual
isn't good sometimes again because
you're on the outside but what i would
say is
uh two things one um the k
being honest unfortunately dan sometimes
we're the first person
that's honest with them about their
basketball abilities
and they need to hear that you know let
me
honestly say you know what do you want
okay what do you want to do you want to
play in the nba well let me honestly
tell
you that you cannot jump shoot your way
to the pros
everybody else has told you that you're
going to have to defend your way to the
pros if you brought
my friend corey blunt who was on that
team on this show yeah
tell you that his agent told him
almost 30 years ago now that he needed
to go show everybody he could shoot and
bob hug and stopped him and said don't
you dare do that at the nba combine
let him guess because you can't shoot
you know go rebound and block shots and
he's a first round pick and played 11
years in the nba so
sometimes we're the first person to tell
these guys the truth
uh and that that you know that's just
you know it's unfortunate but they need
they need to hear it to give themselves
a chance and yeah
it's but the shot i understand you know
sometimes
you know the visual of it's not always
easy if if we had a
coaches one-on-one of the final four
coaches
or three point
how do you fare the
uh so mark mark few you worried about
mark few one one-on-one i'd say
i'd say i'm six to five okay all right
and that's one-on-one what about
three-point shooting some
six to five okay
you know we're all in bad shape i think
you know i think kelvin went
most importantly who wins on the golf
course
and i i got a feeling kelvin wins that
one yeah
you know we're called coach sampson uh
you know we we get
great friendship you know i just got a
feeling he's sandbagging
up the play but we're very close from
our battles
cincinnati and houston so it'll be
interesting you know but the day's
coming we're finally gonna
we're going to get to play but i'd see
you know we're look we're all in the
same hotel which is weird
right so coach you know kelvin and i've
been talking for the last three you know
we've been in this hotel 18 days you
know hey keep winning keep doing it keep
winning casey
we got to win one more to play again how
wild would that be
well congrats so far there coach and uh
good luck this weekend we appreciate
your time as always
it's great to finally uh be on i've been
a fan of the show for a long time
well i just said you need to go with one
name mccronin
like just m-c-c-r-o-n-i-n like
like doesn't it sound like a like a cop
show on cbs or
maybe a movie with jason statham
mccronin
i like no i i like that i mean he you
know i've seen some of his girlfriends
in hollywood
he's going to play me i'm i'm all you'd
be caught once
i like that from one irishman to another
i appreciate it thank you buddy thank
you
that's uh mick cronin mccronin ucla head
coach